uh what kind of man you looking for
honey Tom dominant respectful
financially secure loyal responsible
honest kind authentic thoughtful a good
communicator athletic health conscious
Tom I'm having affectionate emotionally
available he must be a gentleman
hygienic has nice teeth patient
dress sophisticatedly not skinny
everybody got baggage
some people's baggage got them
I have two two kids how old are your
children
23 and one will be 18 on Christmas okay
same here
have you ever been married yeah
yeah okay once you get divorced
September 15th it was finalized oh this
year yes yes guys of course like a month
ago I've been waiting to get on the show
you said gotta be single so hurry up and
got that are you already ready girl I've
been divorced for a month I said it's
time for the next one time Nick yes yes
ma'am you don't have to answer but do
you want to share why you got divorced
um my it was an abusive relationship and
then he turned into a meth addict and um
I mean it was in his I don't believe
that it was his fault that he turned
into a method he was trying to
um sells food I guess um because our
daughter died and we couldn't do
because her daughter died yes I'm also
sorry to hear your weapon to your
daughter
she was run over by the electric company
and then overdosed at the hospital
there's a lot going on here whoa
Casa meth head I'm like okay that's a
method a blogger doesn't want to say
what she's talking about and thought
that I get around geez I mean there's a
lot I'm not gonna lie to you that's just
very understandable what
turning to substance abuse when you lose
a child like yeah that might be the most
relatable thing I can I could think of I
can understand yes because I can assure
even losing in parents like or losing
siblings like return to substance abuse
sometimes like it's not that crazy I can
understand I'm like that's weird then
the reason I was like oh makes perfect
sense uh what kind of man you're looking
for honey okay I got a long list you
have a long list a long list because I
wrote it down um so we get let's be
spiritual
um he needs to enjoy outdoor activities
um he must be calm dominant respectful
financially secure loyal responsible
honest kind authentic thoughtful and
good communicator athletic
self-conscious Tom I'm not finished
affectionate emotion emotionally
available he must be a gentleman
hygienic has nice teeth sorry
sorry the nice teeth kind of [__] me
up because her ex was not enough
[Laughter]
now that you said it sounds like
everything that she's saying is a job at
her ex
you know I mean must have a job
finally
you ever seen those commercials
robbing your mother of every position
she owns isn't normal but our method is
and they got some nasty looking all
these words like
everything she's saying is like a job to
the next patient
dress sophisticated
every time she makes this list longer
I'm like this is so unreasonable and I
just keep thinking
I'm pretty sure you might be wondering
why don't you know
but that's just what I think of every
meth hit you know I just I feel like
they got some change I don't know why
but I think they sound like a bad Batman
villain okay let's go oh
oh um are all these non-negotiable
requirements on your list
um the majority of them are yes
what's negotiable
it's negotiable
um if he has facial hair
which I didn't even say that I do I love
facial hair
um so he has to be athletic yes and so
that's with age range too so I like guys
that are bigger he can't be skinny so
skinny is definitely a non-negotiable
I'm like man yeah like that's for
another reason
in my life
Jesus Christ Hey listen when you're on
mess they're like yeah this man that's
not gay it's it's survival
now what are your deal breakers I'm
assuming you wrote that down I I did
okay so one deal breaker that I have is
that I do not want to date a guy that um
treats women that he's newly dating
based off of
um his previous relationships so I've
dated guys that are like um oh I used to
give you know girlfriends a credit card
when I go to town or something and then
you're like you're going out of town
with my credit card and he's like oh I
don't do that anymore because like chick
the last chick kept my credit card when
we broke up and she was like this is a
very specific answer
foreign
because you can't use his credit card
sounds like you might also do best that
is not an example she pulled out of
nowhere that was very special that was
super specific that was super specific
I'm not okay with you telling me you
know things that you know you do in the
beginning of the relationship and then
tell me oh you're not going to do that
for me because it it went poorly and in
the relationship previously that's not
okay but isn't that why you don't want
to [__] with skinny dudes because your
ex is a meth head who's probably really
scared
ain't you using your previous
relationship to judge your standards for
your future relations that's what I was
about to say now I'm going to keep
watching
but I suspect that the reason people
sent me these videos because she's got
unreasonable centers or whatever I'm not
gonna lie to you personally I'm a little
bit sympathetic mostly because this is
somebody who's been married for a long
time ended up losing her husband due to
their child being killed and they're all
grieving and coming out of it now you
can say This Woman's delusional whatever
it is but like I don't know
you've been married for so long you have
a certain quality of life maybe you're
not ready to start dating again at 40.
this is not like some person who's like
I'm done with this and I just want to be
single because I could do better it's
like you know her situation [__] up it
is that's a [__] up situation and so
part of me has a tremendous amount of
like sympathy in that regards like I'd
probably be really [__] up too coming
out I'm not saying I would have crazy
stains like this but I'm like I don't
know to me it's just one of those things
where I mean I mean on my side I
understand I understand where she comes
from in her situation is
specific is very [__] up yeah it is
but at the same time I'm hearing her
talk and I'm like
I don't think you're ready to date
there's a lot of baggage that you didn't
everybody has baggages right everybody
got baggage from past relationship the
problem is when you go home you take
those baggage and you unfold that [__]
and you put that [__] either in your
drawers or you go you you wash it she
has her luggages with her I'm saying
everybody got baggage
some people's baggage got them
bars
in the desert imagine a bag with a
person inside that's you
my God six foot tall gotta beat that
money God like it's not it's not but
yeah yeah yeah
credit card Mama t-shirt
gotta be up big man gotta hit it hard
now I gotta touch your mouth give me my
heart No More Mess no more drugs don't
want a boy with all this mess all right
I don't know what I'm doing but that's
pretty much it it's like you're not you
didn't deal with all that [__] that
shit's right here that [__] is right
here so I don't think I don't think
you're ready to move on to something
there's a lot of words that hasn't been
done so everybody's got something but
you're latching on to that so anytime
that person is gonna do something that's
triggering your baggage or whatever
you're gonna be like oh [__] oh well I
got a toothpaste and you're gonna open
your baggage and open all that [__] up
to find the thing that triggered you and
that made you naughty
um I don't want a liar I can't have a
lazy guy and he has to be hygienic like
I can have him stink in
um
listen to all our meth viewers I respect
you guys okay the ones watching out of a
cardboard box sucking deal right now to
get some you know I support you
I'm gonna say that this guy has to be
extremely exclusive to me but I
definitely have to feel like I'm I'm the
most important person in your life so
you're open to them having other women
as long as you're the main girl no I
need to feel like I'm the most important
person in your life so if you can
accomplish seeing other people while
still making it snow I feel like I'm the
most important person in your life then
yeah how about it most important person
as in the females he's dating or just
overall most overall the most important
person in your life over his what if he
has children
yeah I will probably have not have
children
um
foreign
did she not say that she had children
yes
my girl
now you have to understand one thing
okay
you have to understand that in your
position you have less and less chances
and your chances are getting very narrow
okay you you're being picky right now
you have less and less chances what I'm
trying to say is that if someone has
AIDS okay they can't really act like
they're a snack your chances of someone
wanting to put up with this is going to
be very narrow you've been all that
difficult about this [__] you're not a
snack you're food poisoning essentially
well that's what I'm saying so you have
to understand that people are not
necessarily going to treat you like the
snack that you think you are you're a
bit going too far now you got kids but
you prefer my girl my girl
more important than other their kids
but when you lost your marriage because
you lost your child maybe that was the
thing he was not moving on and she
wanted him to move on because she had to
be the more important I don't know
speculations we don't know no that's
messed up you got kids and you lost one
and you want that person last just
I think preach nailed it
I am personally like
I think when somebody goes through
something super traumatic like that and
it's fairly recent or whatever
I don't know it's just one of those
things where I'm like I think their
rational Behavior afterwards it's not
that I think you can condone everything
or whatever but it makes it a bit more
understandable yeah and then your
husband turns into a meth addict like
that's that's
you're you're not you're grieving the
dead child you're grieving the living
person that's a lot of grief there and
so I think that part of me subset but
you could also acknowledge and say her
standards are crazy that's just nonsense
stuff but it's hard to tell if that's
just the individual Underneath It All or
just a trauma response to whatever the
[__] has happened in her life which is
pretty pretty extreme so that's probably
my thoughts anything else no no